so this is the sensors touch sensitive
case and it's by a canopy and is a
iphone 4 and 4s case which adds multi
touch capabilities on the back of the
iphone and on the right side you can use
it for gaming or just for reading and
the cool thing is that you don't have to
cover the screen with your fingers well
you're doing what you're doing let me
show you again so you're not supposed to
to swipe the finger on the screen
anymore covering the game but you can
play just touching the rear of the
iphone there's also a camera application
on the four spaces here you can shoot
pictures change the focus change the LED
light and the white balance this is
interesting accessory for me because it
makes easier for you to enjoy the
content that is on the screen of your
iphone this should come by this summer
and should cost between 59 and 99 US
dollars